a ring of fire in the sky seen by lucky
viewers along a narrow path of
visibility in Saudi Arabia Sun chasers
from around the world started preparing
in darkness
I'm Eclipse chaser is my 11 clips and I
specifically came to Saudi Arabia to see
that annular solar eclipse during
sunrise me and my family we live in
London and we've come to Saudi Arabia
especially to see this event because
it's rare it's very rare if we miss it
we have to wait for another 30 years
more Sun Watchers traveled to a remote
desert area of Abu Dhabi for the best
view I think I wanted to come here only
to witness this once-in-a-lifetime
moment and it looks so amazing why you
see it it's like it's completely covered
as the path of visibility moved eastward
people in western Indonesia set up gear
to watch and to record Singaporeans were
amongst the last to be able to see it
the next one is gonna be when I'm in the
my 60s so I might as well take my youth
and look at this lovely Ring of Fire
it's only two minutes but it's so
intense that you talk about it with your
friends and family for the next months
the Eclipse then moved out over the
ocean and disappeared alright to tell us
a bit more about this natural phenomenon
we're joined by Akash Anand
from the Astronomical Society of
Singapore Akash I can hear it's a bit
noisy where you are we're hearing the
Eclipse in fact has already reached its
maximum phase in Singapore where your
did it generate a lot of interest that
seems like quite a lot of people came
out to see it absolutely so we have few
scopes here about 10 to 12 strokes at
passion wave in Singapore then we've had
a few thousand people here who come to
witness the
annular solar eclipse there's been a lot
of interest as you can see the whole
place is crowded we had a few hundred
people all right so we've said that it's
called an annular eclipse now what
exactly does that mean like how is that
different from your ordinary solar
eclipse okay so do three different types
of solar eclipses one of the partial one
is a total and this one what we've
experienced today is the annular so the
annular eclipse is very similar to the
total solar eclipse except for the fact
that the size of the moon appears to be
slightly smaller than the Sun because
the mana slightly further away from the
earth while it is covering the Sun
during the total solar eclipse the size
of the moon and the Sun are almost the
same and the moon covers the Sun surface
totally because of this the annular
eclipse that we experience today the
moon being slightly smaller than the Sun
covers 85 to 90 percent of the sun's
surface and the rest appears like the
ring around the moon so the Sun appears
like a ring and that's why we call it
the ring of fire okay so it does indeed
look like a ring in the sky now tell us
I remember being able you should never
look directly at a solar eclipse is this
the case also by with the annular
eclipse even though most of the Sun is
covered is it dangerous on any given day
during eclipses as well we should not
look at the Sun directly even more so
during it in Eclipse because we tend to
think okay it's going to be duller
because part of the move of the Sun is
covered by the moon and unknowingly we
end up looking at it longer thereby
damaging and damaging the eyes and
exposing ourselves more to the sunlight
the safest way to look at the Sun or an
eclipse is through a solar filter yeah
all right so be sure to use the solar
filter when looking at the Eclipse I got
an aunt from the Astronomical Society of
Singapore we thank you very much indeed